good afternoon everyone uh I'm not too
sure whether I was up to a PRI or a Kare
from last year but given it was W day
yesterday uh and I've spent most of
today sitting in the beautiful mumai I
thought I'd start up with
a
welcome to council for 2024 I hope that
uh everyone had a very restful New
Year's Break um I know to counselors it
won't feel like um the first meeting of
the year as we put in quite a bit of
hard work already um but it is so
looking forward to a prosperous year uh
and seeing what uh ourselves in this
this new government uh get to
deliver do we have any
apologies looks like we're all
here awesome uh conflicts of
interest thank you worship uh just that
letter that was just being presented I
have a conflict of interest in that um
subject for the in committee yes thank
you subject yep noted your worship I'd
like to declare a conflict of interest
in item seven so I will leave the table
when that is up for consideration thank
you Steve
noted any further
conflicts thank you Steve and thank you
counselor uh onto the confirmation of
minutes
uh Tuesday 19th of December
2023 do we have any questions or
comments could I pleas have a move that
they are true and
correct uh councelor MCT Now seconded by
councelor Dixon there is no further
debate I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried any L late urgent
business appears to be none on to the
first item uh adoption of the amended
dangerous and or inry buildings
policy Morgan have anything to add to
the
report uh good afternoon your worship
and thank you and through you uh I have
nothing to add to the report uh it's
fairly straightforward matter um but yes
I at your disposal question if need
be thank you Morgan
councilors uh
councelor if uh council's look on page
17 which is the first part of the policy
in the introduction it refers to the
things that are dealt with in section
131 of the act that must be dealt with
in the policy one is the overall
approach second is the priorities and
thirdly in relation to Heritage
buildings um our policy as drafted does
not deal with
priorities and therefore there there is
a we addition that I would like to see
made to it and and I've handed a copy of
that to the chief executive and I've
actually printed out some um copies that
could go around the room so really I'm
raising up from the point of view that I
feel that it is an Omission um in the
policy and if a copy could go that way
and a copy to Susan and and I'd
appreciate some feedback from Mr Perry
please
through your worship uh thanks uh
councilor hoval yes you're you're right
uh the the policy doesn't really um
address priorities uh it's fair to say
that these matters when they do come to
our attention are afforded a high
priority um because generally they are
they are complaint or slash concern
driven and um the threshold for Incan is
quite high and as recently as just prior
to Christmas we had one issue that we um
got expertise to inspect and concluded
there wasn't an UNC salatary building at
play but more than happy to incorporate
your suggestions uh into the policy um I
do Wonder in terms of process whether
the council is comfortable to to
consider this right here and now or
wishes to have it incorporated into the
the uh policy and resubmitted for final
approval at the next month's council
meeting up the
council from a process point of view if
I can help so the outcomes of this
meeting are dealt with in the minutes
and we confirm the minutes at the next
meeting um so the path of least
resistance would appear to be included
now and if there's any um dissension
that can be dealt with um at the next
meeting so the addition that I've got
there is really saying if something's
really bad action will happen
immediately if it's a little bit less SP
then um the provisions of the ACT will
apply and will be done as soon as
practicable um so it's more a process or
um thing that makes sure that we're
complying fully with the ACT
um thank you Council councel
Phillips uh thank you uh this is a draft
but in page 18 number two um New Zealand
fire service don't exist anymore it's
now called
fi
did we get that as an
amendment thank you
staff any further
comments on this
policy did Council hoval like to put a
motion to the effect of his
recommendation yes I'd I'd like to move
that the policy be adopted with the
correction um of New Zealand fire
service defend and with the uh add is
set out in the handout that I gave um in
paragraph
1.10 thank you counselor councelor
Phillips is the
[Music]
seconder I see that uh councilor mcdal
was
invoicing passing notes in class I see
uh any further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you
councilors item six District plan review
appointment of independent
commissioner it's on page 20 uh did the
interim Chief could like to comment on
that at
all uh thank you your worship reasonbly
straightforward I think the report
speaks for itself um I can tell you that
the district
plan uh Commissioners did have a a good
discussion and meeting with uh Maria
Bartlett and uh felt that she would add
a lot of value to the the process um and
as I said in the report uh she was one
of the um shortlisted people that were
um um if you like endorsed by
hakura uh so I think the way is quite
now uh clear for the council to approve
the recommendation
submitted thank you for that Steve uh
councilors councel as the um chair of
the committee I'd like to move both
recommendations that are there and they
can be dealt with
together uh seconded by Council Dixon
any further
debate I will put the motional there in
favor please say I and against the
motion is carried thank you council is
nice and easy
uh item number seven is the commissioner
recommendation for South and windfarm
resource
consent and I believe we have Katrina
online welcome Katrina did you want to
speak to this item good thank you would
you like to speak to this
item
process through EPA
in as of that alternative
legislation counil opport to rec
commissioner that will be part of the
panel in this
instance
toct
counil
as
the
lead
thank you krina thank you for the report
counselors any
questions no looks straightforward
Council hav that being the case I'd like
to move the recommendation as set out
there um I'd just like councelors to
note that the expert panel um doesn't
put it out for public the proposal for
the wind farm out to public um
submissions uh they decide who is um to
be consulted and the questions to be
asked and the panel who has deemed the
gore District Council to be one of the
effective parties so it actually has the
discretion to come to us and ask ask for
responses on questions they see is
important um the two issues that are
likely to arise are in relation to um
movement of equipment to the site will
be through Gore District Council roads
and there will be connections to the
main power lines that are also within
the district um so they're likely um to
come up at a later date both at um this
level and um through staff um but as I
said I move the
recommendation counselor second seconded
by counselor
guard any more questions or debate I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say I and against the motion is
carried thank you
counselors item number eight on page 31
request to endorse fossil fu
non prolification treaty uh Chief want
to speak to this at
all uh thank you your worship look uh
I'm very um hesitant to speak too much
to this topic I know it's uh it's one
that's probably quite
um uh sensitive and in some areas
because of people tend to have very
strong views in this subject matter um
as I said in my report um one of the
difficulties I guess uh and it's
completely up to the council is um being
asked to um Lobby for the endorsement of
a of a treaty um where that is very much
the domain of central government and
while local government absolutely has to
wear the full effect of climate change
uh and and dealing with um both
infrastructure and communities being at
Peril um whether
the council should Advance its concerns
to degree of uh asking for this um
nonproliferation treaty to be signed um
even though I haven't actually um seen a
copy of the draft is a moot point but it
is absolutely the discretion of the
council politically and uh you you have
been asked by the Oto and Southland uh
region of the uh Anglican Church to um
Into The Fray and lend your support uh
so from an officer point of view uh
really all we can say is um give it your
best uh consideration and um best
wishes thank you thank you for that
Stephen thank you for adding this to the
agenda on my request um as you can see
this was an email sent for me and I feel
like it's fair to include this in
discussion um even though it's it's not
typically what we deal with uh at local
government but I thought it was worth
being on the agenda um given the request
do we have any questions or comments
from counselor counselor
gon just being an agriculture area we
rely heavily on agriculture for um our
income in this this area but we also
have one of the biggest world's
resources of coal and um one day we may
want to mine that and it may be able to
be burnt cleanly or use used for
industry and other avenues and that's
could be a huge industry to us so we
don't want to sign up to a treaty to ban
us from using that resource um we need
to have all our options open into the
future and um if we want to keep our
standard living those sort of options uh
we want to
keep uh that's probably all I need to
say I think i' be totally against this
um treaty us signing up to it
anyway thank you for that counselor um
that's a it's a very interesting
persective thank you uh councelor
Fraser I just want to concur with
councelor Gardine I thought the same we
are a big agricultural area um we I
don't know how the infrastructure for
electricity could work in an area like
this in correct with the coal reserves
it's not something you want to chut away
so I wouldn't be supporting a treaty and
this isn't local government this is
central government
decisions thank you councelor Fraser uh
councelor
McKenzie I basically want to concur with
you folks I think it's very much a
central government matter and we do have
a big pile of that stuff under the
ground here and you never know what the
future holds so I'm just concurring with
my fellow counselors that have spoken so
far thank
you thank you counselors uh with with
three against uh did we want to just
receive and note this is there anyone
who'd like to conure counc Reed happy to
move that thank you councelor councelor
Phillips uh the motion is to the leader
from the an Bishop of denan be received
and noted moved in second I will put the
motion all those oh uh further debate
councelor
guine I just wonder whether we should
recheck
this
yeah we can if that is the
recommendation I think receiving noting
it is is is fine and I don't want to um
make this more political than it needs
to be uh Council
mcf it's it's interesting how we get
ourselves in these positions just
through your worship um yeah obviously I
think we need to listen uh and we need
to receive the recommendation and
actually have it um noted and received I
think would be probably incorrect in
today's environment to completely turn
it down um we do have a a a very very
big
um decision to make in our future and I
think that if you shut down both sides I
think we probably be better off um
making a decision to sit on the fence
put one each way um that would be my
thought I know that for the prime
industry uh yes there's an importance
there yes what does the future bring um
many times we sit around the table here
trying to look ahead if we had a crystal
ball and said that we get cleaning clean
burning systems for coal yes we we may
be sitting in the hot seat for that but
I still believe we have a greater
responsibility to the greater
environment um there is Nations out
there that are struggling with emission
and uh climate situations that are due
to fossil fuel um maybe we can't make a
great uh change in Gore but I think we
should uh be just sitting in that middle
of the road at the moment and actually
receive this to reject it I I wouldn't
reject it
outright thank you counselor so the
motion on the table is still to receive
and note it are we happy to put the
motion getting nods I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say I and
against two against uh councelor Gardine
and councelor Fraser got that
recorded that is yes thank you
councilors next up number nine uh page
34 just before before I hand over to an
to give us a bit of feedback on this
report um councilors may have noticed
that an email uh as of 330 is coming
from uh Melanie Hamilton who is the
principal at M white college there's
quite a bit of information in there um
about this this recommendation in
Constitution I haven't actually had a
chance to read it
thoroughly did we want to allow
counselors to read that and come back to
the item at the end of the meeting or
are we all com pushing
on or we can have a five minute break so
people can read it now I just think it's
important that we actually have this
information in front of us um rather
than 5 minute intermission just so we
can read that email has everyone got
it cool sorry for the interruption
everyone we're just going to take a five
minute intermission and then we'll
resume thank
you
R I've got a bit of a suggestion perhaps
that uh in part of the
recommendations is that they receive the
report that the
council approve the uh the appointment
of two counselors and that we leave out
the section where it says the council
approve the gordis council youth Council
Constitution and let the new Council and
your youth Council make up their own
Constitution and bring it back towards
Council because they may have something
else that they want to add to it we can
use it as a
draft
than
we will kick back into it apologies for
the intermission and apologies to the
public who probably think there's
something suspicious going on um it's
just a recommendation from from the
principle and it's good to get it in
front of us before they before we
discuss this topic um i' i' like can you
hear
me I think we're all good um I'll
continue on uh I think Council Phillips
idea was good good um we we'll look at
the Constitution as it is but it might
be best if the two councils that we
appoint also leas uh with the manager
and with the high schools as well moving
forward before before locking anything
in but we'll add that as as part of the
debate um on not throw to an to add
anything to the
report um the report is based on your
resolution of the 19th of December to um
resolve and Revitalize the structure so
hence you getting the Constitution the
intention um the Constitution does allow
for more than two Representatives on
school we we certainly expected that
there would be more put forward and that
would be up to the counselors and the
new coordinator of the youth Council in
making those decisions um in
recommendation J the intention is that
this now moves over to the corporate
services manager um Lor stra stra who
would um you know manage this process
but I have assured Lune that I would
help her as we transition and I think
it's fairly clear um and if you want to
leave the Constitution and not approve
that today and just work through that
with new youth Council it's absolutely
fine in your
decision um we are asking you to appoint
two counselors to the youth Council so
that we actually have the counselors to
work forward um in the process the you
have two two options um one is the
intention was to advertise immediately
we can either look to appoint the person
at one July which means the funding
would be in the long-term plan and
become available at one at one July
otherwise it would be an un um budgeted
expenditure
item
um and also some feedback on what
committees that you feel youth
counselors should be appointed to so
that that can be a point of discussion
when the first youth counil
mates thank you an councilors uh
questions comments councilor Reed thank
you Mr Mayor um I'm disappointed that
we're not going to work through this
today uh if that's if that's the opinion
of the whole Council and I do have a lot
of comments on what we had before us um
there's massive increase in the budget I
think with having less
people on the council less youth
counselors and less events because
that's obviously the way they're going
they're more focused on learning
procedures and um everyday happenings at
Council um why is there such a huge
increase I'm proposing that we keep it
at the status quo uh there is an
increase of ours also for the
coordinator and I'm quite prepared to
um think about that one but this stage
of it I see you've got less people less
events a large increase and and a huge
cost nearly $30,000 a year just for the
administer uh administrator so I I
really think that we should be looking
at perhaps an 8h hour and a week
increase that's an increase of 3 hours
from the five that are there and totally
between that and keeping the budget at
for events at the status quo at $10,000
I think that saves us
$25,000 a year
um and as to the elected members I think
it should be one counselor and the mayor
if he was willing to do that I think
it's a great option for young people to
be um mentored by a younger person
um and personally um the age group is a
big concern I think we should forget
about the year groups that apply to
school year 11 year 15 and put the age
at
15 and because it just muddies the
waters when you're talking about age
groups and ages so I think 15 year old
and and I think there should be some
capacity for us going forward too to
have an exemption for the young people
that are there that were actually in
that um email which is very um well
written and quite direct that we should
actually be looking
at um just making sure that that as
a an age group only
and that leave them to perhaps come up
with what they want to do but obviously
there's a 360 degree on where they've
been as to where they're going and I
think we need to be very careful with
the money on that side of that and the
ours
so that's just my opinion and I'd be
really Keen to see an exemption for the
ones that are there now who are
currently 13 or 14 they're now in year
10 so they technically would have next
year so what happens between July and
the end of the year to them are they
able to go and sit on the new youth
Council
without I think that's something that
needs to be decided to it's not fair to
them three or four of them that have
been named I know those at least half of
those kids and they're very keen so what
are we going to do not them to back
because they're not 15 no that's just my
opinion I'm happy to be
contradicted thank you councilor Reed
really appreciate those comments I might
get an if she's comfortable to speak
speak about the hours if explain those a
bit further but just before I do I just
want to make it clear um really ke to
debate this right now we may as well get
as much out of the way as we can while
we're together um I think it's just
around confirming it because it seems
like there's quite a bit up in the air
so let's um do that in in cohesion with
the with the high schools and the the
two appointed um and also yes two
Council laws I think needs to be changed
to or me yeah cuz I think that was the
way we were Hing with it um in general
but I I'll throw to an for around the
hour
um so there was 5 hours allocated and
that has proved not to be enough to be
able to develop up a work program and
keep the continuity and things moving
the reason for increase in budget I
think La I think it was sitting at 10 is
that right and that does not allow us to
actually send any of the youth
counselors to any youth events and um so
the mayor might want to comment but
there's several opportunities and it
would be nice if our youth council could
actually participate and right now on
that budget they can
so that was the rationale of trying to
increase it and the intention was also
that working with the elected members to
develop up the work program for when we
go out and look to get nominations so
people know what the work program is
they know what the the project Scopes
are for the year so if you had a if
there was a range of environmental type
things or Community things maybe people
would consider going on the youth
Council because they had an interest in
that for the year um and also we wanted
to be able to include some of those
youth opportunities that exist and our
young people miss out in the local
government space so that was the
rationale of um in Rebecca's report of
you know trying to expand
that thank you for that an um I
understand that that's good and but
maybe it might be a golden opportunity
too for the Youth councilors to raise
funds or apply to other
organizations um for some of that um and
so once those um aims and objects and um
definite programs are sorted would those
AES of the coordinator pull back
then that tends not to be the case
because our experience with the youth
council is there's a lot of chasing goes
on even getting them to come to the
meetings following up on the initiatives
that they're working on so it would
totally depend on the commitment from
the people around the
table thank
you thank you counselor uh and thank you
an counselor
mcf uh yeah thank you through your
worship um I agree with you Roman um
there's a lot of work is going to have
to be done but I wouldn't have a
tendency to put too much money into it
now you got to start off and see what's
going to happen I've looked around a lot
of the different councils eight or nine
councils are the same size as us and
they're doing it very differently and is
driven by the youth in the council as
well the F they do fundraising
themselves and things like that so I
think we've got to look at the whole
thing in a different way and probably
not throw too much I understand what
we're trying to do but don't go too far
too quickly I think um take stock of
what we've been doing and move forward
that way I think in the age group I
think 15 is a good a good one to start
off as
well thank you councelor sorry I'm just
going to chime
uh quickly just on
the the the hours and I think it it's
largely dependent on on the age and and
also the capability of the cheer as well
and the involvement they have I think if
you have a really good cheer who's
really involved they can pull that
together and and that may be our
downside by not having counselors on it
this this time around to help influence
and help guide that chair but I I feel
like if we do that then the financial
burden I'm just touching on what an was
talking about in terms of uh budget line
I went to f or the future I don't know
if any of you heard about it um in
Wellington last year um basically every
Council that was there had their entire
youth Council there um for us being so
far away that wouldn't be practical but
it would be really great if we could at
least send one that's a gosh how many
days was it uh I think it was two days
experience in Wellington getting to to
see everything there is to offer from
from Innovation to to government to all
sorts of different things so it's a
great opportunity to be able to send the
cheer to um but as an alluded to um
there's not the budget to do that at
this point in time um there was barely
any to to get myself up there and just
coincided with another meeting uh I
think I had councelor Stringer oh no
he's
he's he's all good uh councelor
mcdonell yeah I agree with councilor
Reed and Council M's comments that we uh
age of 15 seems fine to me uh giving
dispensation to the the ones that are
already on the council I'm fine with
that and uh I think we we need we're in
a very tight financial position here we
think we need to keep a tight rain on
the costs so I can with all that I think
we need to start there and then we need
to look at it further as it develops and
if there's more money needed they can
make a case case for it when when when
we get
there thank you councelor councelor
McKenzie I'm basically concurring with
what you're saying I think you should
start it off quietly and see if the en
enthusiasm is still there in 6 months
time because it might kick off with a
hiss and a Roar and as other interests
come into
it the enthusiasm may disappear so I'd
be in favor of starting off very quietly
Finance was and then in 6 months time if
the enthusiasm is still there well we
could relook it but there's no point if
they're all going to if they start
wandering off in other
directions thank you thank you counselor
I'll get to you in a second Council um
I'm just thinking on the Fly here would
it be beneficial to counselors for the
two members that are appointed to the
youth Council to report back within the
first three months of the youth Council
so that they actually have some insight
into budget and constraints and how it's
going because I feel like that's the
oversight we haven't quite had of what
it looks like when we've actually got
consistent counselor engagement does
that seem practicable we'll Circle back
to that recommendation time uh
Council
um I've got a question first and that is
what is proposed in the interim by this
year I'm not understanding of
it and are you happy to speak on that I
think that depends on what you decide
today if you decide you want to run with
the current Council we can get in touch
with them and we can um get them going
the problem we have right now is
workload and no resource the intent
ition was that we would immediately look
to appoint someone if you tell us what
the budget is and the amount of hours so
I guess having a couple of councilors
appointed that we can work
with would be good okay so um thank you
for that that that clears my mind so the
existing youth councilors would carry on
this year and I think the most practical
way ahead given the issues that we have
with finances at present um given given
the email that came in given some of the
comments that I've heard that that that
are really uh uh good comments
particularly in terms of the age um I I
think the the best we can do today is to
appoint um two elected representatives
not necessarily two counselors but
appoint two elected um representatives
to work with the current youth
counselors and to report back to us
further the implication of that is that
I think it would be unwise until we have
sorted out
um as part of our long-term plan uh a
appointment at the stage I think that
needs to be worked through um in in the
long-term plan framework um both in
terms of dealing with numbers I think if
we tried discussing um providing a
budget to that group
today um it it would be um just shooting
from the hip and not necessarily
particularly well informed and so I'd
like to see some further information um
on that age 15 totally um agree with um
so if we were to look at the um
um key recommendations that that are
there I think we can receive the report
and and I'd like to move that move that
but at the same time uh to nominate his
worship the May and councilor Paul mcf
to be the two uh elected representatives
to the youth
Council thank you council could I have a
second for those recommendations councel
Reed uh I will continue the discussion
uh yeah councelor councelor
dexon thank you
worship um look I agree with what is
being said as well and I think 15 is a
good age um for youth counselors I also
there is a question in my mind and maybe
the public would be asking this as well
would these councilors have voting
rights and I think we need to make that
very clear whether they'll be at our
meetings um for a discussion and input
only they're not actually
elected counselors so I understand they
wouldn't have voting
rights no same same as man
representation it's just there as a
voice to to provide input but wouldn't
have voting rights just clarifying
that uh Council go on yeah I'd agree
with the um 15 years and up um and also
I think I do agree we need to appoint
the appointees from Council today but um
we need to look at the long-term plan
and where the money will fit but the
other thing the community is out there
would actually help in getting people to
these events with sponsorship and
funding if you had the program set out
and and you advertise well and um people
will get behind their young people and
uh we don't have to rely totally on rate
payers
thank you counselor uh just on the 15
years can I throw a different angle on
it and I might need a little bit of help
here counselor Reed uh is that year
10 so is it better to have year 10 I
know that just 15 so even if
you're
okay gets too confusing yep that's cool
just being a a young uh year 13 as it
was um being left behind but that's okay
they can they can do it in year even if
they so please uh councelor re just
wondering too if we could have something
in the new
constitution um that the councilors or a
representative each perhaps a counselor
every time we have our full council
meeting if they've been doing something
to come and address us the council let
us know what they're doing um because
that was always something that the kids
look forward to um and would come and
address the counselors I think it's
important it gives contact for us and it
actually en endorses what they've been
doing as
well so you would like I'm just again
thinking on the Fly minutes taken at the
youth Council and then a youth Council
coming and presenting on those those
minutes I think that can be added to our
agenda no isue uh councelor Phillips
been patiently
waiting uh thank you worship um I
totally agree with the uh year5 and not
year 10 because I'm one of those old
people that don't understand what year
10 is um
I'm going to go I'm going to go against
the the norm here and we asked the staff
to write a report about what was the
projective about to get the youth
Council up and running it's here in
front of me and they they want 16 hours
a week I work part time and 16 hours a
week is not very
much
and I think I think if the the vision of
the two of of Paul and yourself to what
the count the youth Council can
B 16 hours is not going to take long to
to burn it up right and I and I'm
looking at July 1 uh as a cut off point
and I think if we if we don't make a um
a solid decision today then it's going
to drag on and by the time it comes to
longterm plan we definitely won't have
the capacity to do it and we got to
think about around the table and I look
around the table and say who wants to
take my place and and it has to be
someone from 15 years and or year 10 in
the
future so if we don't invest in them and
we keep Dilly ding around we went to
sleep with the last Council we went to
sleep on them and I can't I can't well
some of us did and I can't let that
happen again and I and I I'm endorsing
this um report except for a couple of
things about the Constitution that i'
like to just to change up so I'm going
against the rest of the council's about
waiting to SP the money on this one
sorry thank you councelor uh councelor
rich
mcf thank you worship
um yeah uh interesting discussion we've
had so far um one thing I will bring up
is that we always remember as a
counselor with governance and that we
don't want to dwell too far into the
operational capacity of how a matter
actually hits the ground and in light of
that I believe that capacity within the
council is one of the the the
fundamental principles of actually
getting this up and running and I have
to place a Reliance on the
professionalism maturity of the staff to
be able to indicate how many airs would
be involved in doing that I know we have
Financial constraints but if we want to
start on something that's going to lose
what why start so that's my first point
so I have a Reliance set of 16 hours as
the indication to get things running
operationally I'll take that um the
second thing is uh and I totally agree
with uh councelor Reed and councelor
Paul mcf around they have the knowledge
they're working and and I know councelor
Reed with a great deal of respects been
involved in this before and can
understand the ages and and what's
entailed here and I think the age is
correct what she stated there and I
fully support how that would go um so
I'm siding with the fact that I think
that to to achieve this we will need
some Financial input the last thing I'll
do say as as a challenge we spent 5
minutes um stopping in regard to this
topic to deal with information coming in
from the uh the principle of our largest
school role I put the challenge out
there to the schools to the teachers
that if we're taking kids and as Council
representatives there should be a
component of them assisting us with
doing that and actually being involved
with Council uh they do it with combined
sports teams debate teams um you name it
so what's difference between Council
representation and local politics and
and any other team that comes so we
should actually go back and say to them
you know perhaps you should give us some
support as well um we're we're we're
encouraging enhancing and and going to
be working with these kids to to to B
there tomorrow so um and the other thing
is that in this day and age they seem to
be able to get uh credits for getting
the driver's license in NCA well why
don't they get a credit for um being in
local politics um throw that out there
as well thank you
wow Council fail it
was a fair fair few recommendations in
there very well spoken it was that was
uh yeah some a lot of process actually
um very good
indeed do we have any other comments
around the table I'm I'm I'm sensing a
middle ground um I know we've got option
one and option two in front of us and
fully acknowledge his emotion um in the
ear do we want
to I'm cautious of our ltp and wanting
to keep a budget line in there I I fully
appreciate that it may
change but I also don't want to leave uh
a lovely La um high and dry having to
remove a budget line and then put it
back
in are we okay with option two with the
condition that the two nominees come
back to council between now and the lotp
to discuss that budget line and see
whether it's actually
appropriate hey happy happy with that
Council got on probably probably don't
like the wording option two of been
unbudgeted expenditure in this
year sorry my my apologies option one
not option two option one so it would
start from uh first of July but uh
myself and Paul if appointed uh would
return back to council with with an's
help and give Clarity on that budget
line did any want to say anything to
that I would just want some
clarification around the hours because
for this for us to progress this piece
of work we need to advertise a position
and get some staff and so we need to be
able to go to the market and say what it
is that we're looking for so are we
sticking with a 5 hour position an 8
Hour position a 16h hour position or are
we going to advertise and say that the
hours may increase like I just need some
guidance on that because we will want to
start the ball rolling if um because the
message I'm getting is we keeping going
here
um correct me if I'm wrong counselors
but it's continuing with the 5 hours for
the interim and pulling the existing
youth Council together and then having
that conversation about what that role
May entail and how many hours that may
require with both myself and Paul in
that conversation with yourself is that
correct with reporting back
before as soon as possible for the ltp
council
thank you worship I just think that
makes it very awkward to advertise the
position because we have no they have no
idea what they're advertising at the
time how many hours you could say five
with the expectation of it being more
or how would that
work sorry it would be not advertising
at this stage and just keeping the five
hour have we got capacity for that 5
Hour we've got no capacity so we
actually have to look to get the
capacity to go forward the only reason
we we scrambled through last year
because we lost a staff member and then
um we had another person offered to pick
up those five hours and um they don't
want to do that basically um yeah so we
need to get a people resource to
actually be able to do
this
councilor mcdonell do you have a comment
are you're right take your time I think
everyone's thinking it's all right bit
of a CLE no uh sorry uh we just we had a
staff member and he left that was part
of his job wasn't it and we replace that
staff
member we had another staff member who
was in the building who actually kindly
picked up the current youth Council
through to the end of December and is no
longer contracted to do
that count something fa s right I'm
trying to get this work there were we
aware of
this I just want to know cuz we want to
be able to help you because that doesn't
sound very good right we've let left the
youth Council behind we can't have that
happen again we need to give you the
resources but we got to be aware of that
cuz I didn't know that so we've actually
ran a workshop with the council and we
outlined all of the information and we
had Rebecca come and speak through our
challenges and the aim was to try and
get this through so that we could get up
and
running councel dexon and councel
Gardine thank you worship um for your
worship could I ask CEO um
Steve present there's um or La present
there's 10,000 in the budget for youth
council is is that
correct three you um the $110,000 runs
from the 1 of July 2023 to 30th of June
2024 half of the $10,000 has already
been spent for the first six months of
the year so there's about $5,000
remaining traditionally that has been
spent on the events and the activities
that the youth Council has has done
rather than rather than
Salary thank
you uh Council go on no council m still
still confused here we had an employee
who who used to do this where I I can't
remember his name but he had a motorbike
accident then he left us uh have we
replaced that
employee or not
or how do we do that because there must
have been a budget there
there uh through worship look the that
position uh has been filled but uh the
youth Council part of that position was
really just an informal adjunct to the
job and the key point of all this is
that historically the youth Council uh
the support provided by staff has
usually been a bit of an elbow to
someone say would you mind giving us a
few hours of your time to actually
support the youth Council we've never
really had a absolutely dedicated
person um that's if you'd like official
part of the job description we've had
sometimes people on a very small 5H hour
type contract um but the the resolution
of the council back in December was that
you wanted to reinvigorate and resource
adequately the youth Council to give it
the best possible chance to success uh
so that's what is before you
today thank you Steve Council Val from a
practical Viewpoint if we gave approval
to advertise today when would we
realistically expect someone to take up
the position and what would be the cost
of that for the that remaining part of
the financial
year I.E if we were to approve something
today what would it cost us this
financial
year I'm going to jump in for an because
I've had this discussion and I I think
it's a little bit outlined in the report
but it would be unbudgeted expenditure
from from this point on what what that
number is depends on the role and how
many when we when we actually get the
applicant in which depends on the
recruitment process the other option is
we budget it and put it from the 1st of
July but if we're going to advertise now
it'll be unbudgeted expenditure so
whatever the cost we're going to have to
figure it out next right but but I'm
trying sorry I'm trying to establish are
we talking about $110,000 5,000 20 for
the rest of this financial
year perhaps I can assist you uh through
your worship look a best guess if you
said okay we'll advertise now and put
the foot down logic suggests you
probably have someone starting and it's
not right one April which is B in the
middle of Easter but probably towards
the end of of March so you're looking at
3 months of roughly uh unapproved
expenditure um so if it's
20 30 ID by four is uh 7 and a half
so
y
not sure that's quite how it works but
I'll throw it to one
a that that would leave the youth
council with no funds to spend towards
any activities that they were doing in
that in that period of time so you need
to consider that along with the with the
salary salary implications but it is it
is in the scheme of the council it is
smaller than some of the other
unbudgeted exps we've
had
councilor
Phillips thank you your it's going to
take you at least six weeks or so to get
meet with the council the original youth
councilors get what their aspirations
are get the Constitution up and running
so in the meantime you're not going to
spend any money on the events are you
let's take him out to doore park for a
picnic with what funds
counselor sorry was setti sorry I can
pay for
them uh councilor Fraser yeah this is
going around around in circles we did
ask for a report to come back to us with
recommendations we've now gone through
this and gone do we like this do we not
I like the suggestions that are there we
need to reinvigorate it or Let It Go
that's as simple as that um and if they
want to fund some events I agree with
Council MC they can fund ra but and I
agree with with councelor Richard mcf
with the
schools um yes maybe you could come
along and help you want your children to
go through this journey you're there
with them we will be there with them but
I I I agree with recommendations age and
everything else but I think we're just
going to keep talking round around the
circles we just need to make a decision
quickly thank
you counil mcf look I think we need to
move a recommendation and I think what
Keith saids right we've got to fund them
from you know up till July get things
moving of some form otherwi we've let
them down both the council and all of us
here we've let them down we've got to
try and do something to get started and
we got to build off something and I
think that's what we're going to do so
Keith whatever you said and how much it
was figures going around um I think we
should start from there what was
that it was about 7 12,000 I thought it
was yeah 75,000 for uned expenditure
councelor councilor
MD just try and get some Middle Ground
here on this money and I'm never in
favor of spending money you know me uh I
think if I was try to advertise this
position I'm trying to think of the
staff here I'd advertise this a 0.25 ft
which is 10 hours a week it's it's
doubling the hours that we' got now and
work from there if it pans out that we
need to increase it you can talk to the
person that applies for the job you can
put that in there that the hours May
expand out a bit but if we stick at the
base of 0.25 of an FTE when you talk of
advertising you usually talk points of.
2.25 uh four or whatever so I would
advertise it like that that gives us
some middle ground and cut Cuts our
costs a wee bit in the
meantime I just see
if sorry sorry councils this is going to
be extremely rude um can I ask for a 5
minute intermission um there's just been
uh a several defense emergency call set
up with with the MS are under a
declaration so um could we have a 5
minute intermission will I jump on this
um to see what what's happening thank
you very much Council as apologies for
the
interruption